I mean we are here honoring Bradley
Cooper does that make you light up it
just makes my heart sing I'm so happy to
be here tonight he is such an incredible
director and you know he made me a
better actress and I just loved him so
much and he's such a dear friend of mine
and I'm just so proud to be here tonight
I know you talked about that trust he
created for you what has it been like
now that filming is over but you guys
are in this crazy awards season time
what is your relationship like now how
often are you talking and reaching out
to him and getting support we talk all
the time yeah we talk all the time and
it's exciting and wonderful and and
we're both so grateful for how the film
is being received and you know that's
what's really come out all of this for
me you know the reward of a lifetime
friendship someone I deeply respect well
we are hoping to see an Oscars
performance what could you tease about
what that would look like
I can tease and with nothing at all
[Music]
[Applause]